well Jordan is the particular analyst
probably the best analyst of American
politics there is Frank Luntz so I'm
glad to say is with me here in London
and across the bond Fox News contributed
to an outkick host Tommy lahren and by
Michael wolf author of The phenomenally
s-selling fire and fury inside the Trump
White House okay well look great to see
you all Michael Wolff let me start with
you uh you know Trump as well as anybody
you wrote the devastating series of
books about him
um can he wriggle off all these hooks I
guess is the obvious question could you
see a pathway now for Donald Trump
to just Barrel his way once again to the
White House
well yeah yeah I mean I think that the
answer is uh um of course I mean he has
done it so many times before that it
would be actually more surprising if
this finally trips him up I mean I I got
a note from one of the the Trump Inner
Circle this morning that said we're in
unchartered territory which I think is I
think is is true uh to be found liable
for
um for um sexual abuse in the middle of
a presidential campaign is um well
unprecedented but is that will this have
an effect on the campaign it will
certainly have an effect on the people
who hate Trump but the question is will
it have an effect on the people who love
Trump
um as so many things in the past uh that
we thought would have an effect have not
so it's uh it is unchartered we wait and
see yeah it is uh Tommy Lauren I want to
play a clip from Chris Christie who may
well end up running against Trump to be
president he was on Fox News Radio and
said this
you know his response yesterday to me
was ridiculous that he didn't even know
the woman I mean you know how many
coincidences are we going to have here
with Donald Trump Ryan I mean he must be
the unluckiest SOB in the world he just
has you know random people he's never
met before who are able to convince the
jury that he sexually abused them I mean
this guy it's one person after another
one woman after another the stories just
continue to pile up and I I think we all
know he's not unlucky
um that he he engaged to this kind of
conduct
all right so I mean give me some defense
for Donald Trump here
it's not a matter of being unlucky it's
a matter of the world wants to take this
man down I mean every time I hear a
charge against Donald Trump some drummed
up charge I swear my head is going to
explode they go after this man over and
over and over and over again over some
BS ridiculous charges and let's also
keep in mind that this jury did not find
him liable for rape they said that they
did not believe this woman that he raped
her but then again they're going after
him for defamation I don't know about
you pierce but if someone falsely
accuses me of rape I think that it's on
and popping you can say whatever you
want about somebody who falsely accuses
hang on yeah they didn't just find
against him for defamation they found
against a sexual assault right so he was
not found guilty of the higher charge of
rape but he was certainly found guilty
by this jury in a civil case it must be
said the different bar of course to a
criminal case but he was found guilty by
a jury of sexually assaulting this woman
yeah and again the same woman that went
on CNN and said that rape was sexy okay
I'm sorry if I have a little bit of
Suspicion here and this honestly as a
woman really bothers me because there
are people with legitimate sexual abuse
and assault and rape claims that don't
come forward for this exact reason
people that make a mockery of it like
this woman e Gene Carroll who wants her
moment in the Sun and her moment in the
spotlight they go after this man
relentlessly and then meanwhile you've
got the Biden crime family over there
amazing that we're focusing on this and
not the fact that we know now that that
the bidens were involved in a massive
bribery pay-to-play scheme the fact that
the media continually focuses on Donald
Trump and not what's actually going on
with our current sitting president to me
is an Abomination all right Franklin
um let's get to the the polling on all
this because it's really interesting
because after the indictment over the
Stormy Daniels case which I thought was
overreach frankly
um it looked to me like if you made
those payments he was doing it probably
to keep this clock from his wife and is
that really the correct way to go go
after a a president of the United States
to take him down for that I don't think
so I think there are more important
legal issues to come but what was
extraordinary was after that indictment
is poll numbers surged and so did his
fundraising it was almost like you give
us a reason to get behind this martyr
and we're gonna do it will that happen
again now after this do you think and
you've got the exact word martyr I like
to call it it's not even
victimization it's now persecution and
Donald Trump is the perfect political
person who understands communication and
is United all these Republicans against
those who are attacking them and the Fox
News host she did it right there
but I want to bring it down a little bit
because I know what you think about
America as do I there's a reason why I'm
here
we're destroying our democracy we
actually are more Americans think our
institutions have failed more Americans
believe our elections are fraudulent
more Americans believe democracy does
not work more Americans have lost faith
and confidence in the future and most
importantly more Americans today than
ever before think their kids are going
to be worse off than they are
Pierce we're destroying
this gift that we were given it's not
entertainment for me it's not being a
pundit for me I'm watching my country
while I'm alive I'm watching my country
tear itself apart and the problem is
that Donald Trump is leading that effort
it's not about the truth to him it's and
by the way elections are less important
than the future of our democracy right
obviously we have trouble here in the in
Great Britain
but America's become the laughing stock
I mean Michael Wolff
I have to say a lot of the world is
shaking their head going you've got 320
million people in America and you have
two potentially a runoff again between
two people one of whom will be 82 if he
wins the election 86 by the end who is
already showing visible signs of
senility and the other one is already
under criminal indictment has just been
found guilty by a civil jury of sexual
assault as a number of other legal
threats coming down the line a lot of
people away from America scratching
their heads going how is it that it's
going to be these two
facing off to become the most powerful
person in the world
well I I hope you're not asking me to
answer that question because I have I
have no idea I mean it's it is it is it
is kind of astounding
um
um I yeah you know I mean somebody was
saying to me the other day well you know
we always love a rematch
so it is is is is that part of this that
we are seeing and we now regard all of
this as as an incredible show that these
are all characters engaged in some kind
of I don't know media event
um and um and who is responsible for
that well Fox certainly has
responsibility in that
um and uh you know all other cable
channels have responsibility for that
but right now we have a debt ceiling
that we cannot solve right we have a
budgetary crisis we have a crisis in
terms of our relationship with China all
of this is having a negative impact on
actually getting things done but you
also I think you have a paralyzed
Washington in the sense that the first
thought now for any side that loses an
election is how to spend the next four
years preventing whoever wins from doing
anything so yeah and this has been going
on now for a long time and I look at
didn't think I'm not sure how you solve
that problem so you're correct you're so
correct but then the question is what
does the media do in this process or are
they playing as as Mike Wolf says are
they playing characters in this Broadway
play well CNN tonight I'm going to be
doing this big town hall Caitlin Collins
one of their correspondents will be
interviewing Donald Trump in front of a
lot of Republican voters apparently big
departure for CNN who are full on Trump
bashing for a number of years but you
know again you can already see a huge
Fury erupting about them even doing this
but Trump is a Bonafide candidate to be
president why shouldn't CNN do it but
already I can say this is going to play
out in a horrendously toxic way whatever
happens but some of this is our fault as
voters our fault as Citizens we seek
news that
affirms us rather than informs us we
just want to be confirmed we surround
ourselves with people who agree with us
you can't even have a political
conversation at Thanksgiving or
Christmas without interrupting so the
problem is and by the way
I actually I'm going to blame social
media more than any other Factor no
question it's a poison and it's time for
Facebook and Google and all those
companies to set down and acknowledge
the damage that's already happened and
address it let me bring tell me tell me
I mean tell me the big question for me
for the Republicans is I felt for a
while the only way Joe Biden might be
able to win in 2024 is if Donald Trump
is his opponent again because he's
beaten him once he knows he'll get the
anti-trump vote out Trump has probably
got the power to win the nomination for
the party but I'm not sure he can win
enough Independence for example to
become president why would the
Republicans willfully engage in an act
of self-harm when you've got for example
a candidate like Ron DeSantis the
Florida governor who's been very
successful he's nearly half Trump's age
years ago any of the baggage I don't
really get this strategy here
well you know Pierce I'm sorry Michael
that was just true there Michael that
was the Tommy I'll come to you for a
response to Tommy but Tommy that one was
for you can you sure
Tommy can you hear me
I don't think she can that's the who
song we're going to fix Tommy's uh here
because I don't think she's gonna hear
me Michael you answer them
yeah you know I mean that I I think I
think what you point out is the weakness
of the situation to suddenly posit Ron
DeSantis and that's that's the only
person that that the Republicans or and
the media establishment have been able
to posit oh Ron DeSantis can run against
against him and do well but everything
that we've seen except in the local
Florida election Ron DeSantis is an
incredibly untried and weak candidate
he's a he's actually a bad retail
politician
um which is and and against Donald Trump
one of the greatest retail politicians
of all time
yeah the only the only caveat I would
put in that is that if you looked at the
recent midterms most of Trump's
endorsements lost or did badly and
DeSantis was the standout Republican
winner taking a majority of thirty or
thousand absolutely not a million I mean
he has got the scores on the board
well in Florida but we've seen again and
again and again and again in the history
of presidential races Governors who
can't step out of their own State it's a
really it's an entirely different skill
set to deal with national media over
over local media and local media
yeah that is true let me bring in Tommy
I was going to ask you about the Santa
something but your ear fell out so we've
got your ear back so I want to ask you
about somebody else George Santos
strikes me as the only person where
Donald Trump looks at him and goes wow
now that guy that is Shameless
um I interviewed him in New York
recently and we had this Exchange
I've been a terrible liar I mean would
you be prepared to say that sure like I
said well I've been a terrible liar on
those subjects
I've been a terrible liar to George
Sanchez but he's now been arrested for
being a terrible liar and he's such a
thing 13 charges for his lies but he
says tonight I'm not going to resign he
intends to return to Congress to vote
tomorrow and intends to run for
re-election how is America again I ask
you as a nation you're speaking of your
country here how can someone like George
Santos who literally lies about whether
the sky is blue how can he still be
operating in Congress
well again because I am a conservative
and a republican I don't stand up for
people just because they are a
conservative or republican so I'm not
going to stand up for George Santos I'm
not going to defend him right I think we
can do much better as a Republican party
as conservatives but I do find it
incredibly interesting tears that the
rest of the mainstream media chose to
run with the George Santos story today
which impacts very few people when you
really look at it instead of running
with James Comer and health house
oversight over the Biden crime family
which I've been trying to address
because we could have potentially the
then vice president current president
taking money from foreign entities like
China in the millions of dollars over a
span of several years but yet we're
talking about George Santos I'm not
defending the man but my God you've got
a man sitting in the White House who has
not been held accountable for what his
family has done what his son has done I
really wish song would talk about that
certainly has implications for our
entirety of our national security right
and certainly frankly I was just finally
I mean that there is a double standard
about the way Biden is treated by the
media because a lot of the media do
skewed to the left and I do think if it
was the Trump family that had this kind
of murky stuff going on with all these
payments coming into the family from all
these uh foreign adversaries in many
cases they'll be all hell would be
breaking loose what should I go back to
your original point is this the best we
can do
and that the ad that's going to kill
Donald Trump in the end is going to be a
middle-aged woman looking at her
daughter who's turning 18 and asking her
is this the person you're proud of is
this the person you find as a role model
is this the best person we can put up
for president of the United States it's
going to be asked as a question this is
not about entertainment am I concerned
in this whole conversation
is that we're trying to score political
points and I mean this you you know me
this is not about political points at
some point you break your democracy at
some point the public lose well I do
think your point about social media I do
think it's got so tribal on social media
facts no longer matter all that matters
is getting on your tribe side and
agreeing with whatever the tribe has
decided is the agreed line and facts are
getting disintegrated I've got to leave
it I could talk about this all day long
and it's great to have you here Frank
please come back soon Michael thank you
very much over there across the pond and
thank you Tommy it's going to be
fascinating to watch how this all plays
out but again I asked the question I
asked at the start really America this
is the best you can do come on